if he can escape to the Ozark and get
away clean that's good for him but it's
not much of a story there's no story if
we don't make the bad situation worse
that's why we make the bad situation
worse because it drives
story why is it important for a comedy
writer to get in the habit of making a
bad situation
worse when we look at what happens on
the level of a joke or a level of a
comic scene
we're we're trying to figure out how to
build the story how to advance
toward a Moment of Truth toward an
explosion of new understanding and the
strategy that gets you from the
beginning of the story to the end of the
story is making bad situations worse
over and over again uh this will sound
like an oddball example but you can look
at Star Wars as an example of a story
that's built on making a bad situation
worse Luke uh is all alone on the planet
hanging out everything's okay his
parents are killed he's taken off his
home planet he's under threat he's being
attacked his life is in danger finally
he finds his way into the Rebel Alliance
and he discovers the force but he
doesn't want to use the force he doesn't
know if he can in the Moment of Truth he
tries not to use the force and then he
uses the force all of the pressure
that's been put on him from the start of
the story to that moment brings him to
the Moment of Truth where he says I was
wrong not to embrace the force the force
is the answer to everything he Coes
through an explosive transformation from
denial to acceptance of the truth and
that explosive transformation from
denial to acceptance of the truth is the
goal and destination of most stories and
virtually every comic story so how do we
get to that moment of explosive
transformation from denial to acceptance
pressure pressure pressure pressure more
pressure bad situation worse another
example that comes to my mind is The
Wedding Singer do you know this movie
Adam Sandler plays A Wedding Singer who
needs to be a songwriter if his
girlfriend doesn't break off their
engagement he never becomes a songwriter
cuz his situation isn't bad but when she
leaves him he M it makes his bad
situation worse then when it gets fired
it's worse still then when he falls in
love with Julie
guli uh Julia whatever her name is it
it's worse and worse and worse until it
finally comes to the moment where he
says I can no longer go on denying my
truth that I need to transcend my fear
and be the person time intended to be a
songwriter a Creator someone in control
of his Destiny if we don't put him under
pressure if we don't make his bad
situation
worse we never get we never give him the
reward that the audience wants so that's
why you make a bad situation worse and
going back to our earlier discussion
about conflict this is how you tell
yourself it's okay to make your
character suffer it's okay to put them
in conflict because you're bringing them
to a new understanding that they very
much want and can't get there on their
own similarly in Emily the criminal
she's trying to to get a job and
actually go the right way and then
circumstances change and she's given
this opportunity for this survey and and
Things Fall Apart from there so her
situation becomes just dire because now
she has like a no way out she's she's
not even if she wants to get out she can
she's already sort of built these walls
that she's trapped in sure and and in
that sense especially in this day of
streaming entertainment we can really
see make a bad situ situation worse is
the DNA of not just comic storytelling
but dramatic storytelling thinking about
I'm thinking about Ozark right
now if he can escape to the Ozark and
get away clean that's good for him but
it's not much of a story there's no
story if we don't make the bad situation
worse that's why we make the bad
situation worse because it drives story
it's also funny I mean uh right now I'm
thinking about John C in a movie called
Clockwork where he is trying to get from
one place in England to another place
against a ticking clock and every
attempt he makes to travel or Planes
Trains and Automobiles same thing every
attempt he makes to travel makes the bad
situation worse it's not just that the
plane won't go home it's the train won't
and the car won't and the whole thing
breaks down and it just gets funnier and
funnier how can we attack a character's
peace to attack a character's piece and
thus make a bad situation worse we
simply ask ourselves what does this
character want and how can I keep them
from getting it because their peace will
be achieved if they get what they want
and any roadblocks that we put between
themselves and what they want will
attack their peace I'll give you an
example this is the one I use all the
time in classrooms I'm a teacher in a
classroom what do I want I want to teach
effectively I want people to learn what
I have to teach them I want to have a
good teaching experience it's obvious
now in comic
terms if we want to make that moment of
teaching funny we remember thing isn't
funny the person that's happening to so
I'm not going to enjoy what happens but
if the fire alarm goes off or if
somebody comes in thinking it's a
different kind of class or somebody's on
their phone or everybody falls asleep or
I start burping uncontrollably or
hiccuping uncontrollably my bad
situation is getting worse and worse I'm
getting further away from my peace
because the thing that I want is being
blocked by new and successive Road
Blocks so this all ties together when we
speak of attacking a character's piece
we simply think about what does he want
how can I keep him from getting it and
how can those roadblocks make him change
so that he finally can get what he
wants let's let's let's follow the
example let's say I'm a teacher in a
classroom but I'm
uptight like
I'm very stiff and what I need is to be
loose I need to let go can't teach
effectively until I let go everybody
with me so far now I'm uptight and I
don't want to let go and fire alarm
didn't make me let go and a guy on his
cell phone didn't make me let go and the
principal walking in and casting an eye
at me didn't make me let go but when
that brass band next door started
playing I just lost it and I lost it so
magnificently and
completely that I had a cathartic
experience and I realized well I guess
if you saw me do that you should be okay
with what I have to teach you next now
that I'm changed now that I'm not so
afraid of not teaching you now at last I
can teach you you know funny you're
you're triggering a real life memory in
that at my school uh some high school
students were able to rig the PA system
where they played the Howard Stern Show
and they played the Fartman bit and one
of the teachers supposed just lost it
and he went and dis dismantled he just
kind of ripped it from the wall the
speakers because they couldn't get it to
stop and so you had I'm sorry you fig
it's still funny after all these years
it's still yeah many years and it's very
funny not funny to him no it wasn't but
and it got around to the whole school
and so to that just envisioning that and
I guess he was sort of an uptight
teacher I didn't know him personally but
just to know that he couldn't prevent
this like vulgar radio show from coming
through the airwaves just s i i I have
very little patience for people who are
overcommitted to
propriety uh if
you're if if if you're committed to your
rules if you're married to the rules uh
I'm going to have a devilish desire to
subvert you it's just in my nature so
yeah I probably was would have been the
one to pipe that Howard Stern Show into
the classroom
h